name five things beginning with P
potatoes pants Paris paparazzi and what
is up guys I'm ASA and Emma I'm shooty
and we're about to play animal timers
for that Bible and the time it takes
this dog to squeeze through the wall
named five parts of the human body I
didn't have the toe you got the thumb in
the time it takes this dog to climb one
step named for social media websites
Twitter Instagram Facebook and the time
it takes this cat to give up on life
blessing in the time it takes this cat
to give up name for sports athletics in
fact wanna know handball basketball
volleyball and the time it takes this
dog to ascend to the ceiling for
romantic comedies oh they're not the
ones who answer this question
Oh things I hate about you yes I was too
distracted by the boys hit the seal a
sad in the time it takes this cat to
make a leap of faith
name three flavors of crisps and shapes
okay
I saw a min ago cheese and onion proper
kill in the time it takes this rat to
eat a piece of popcorn named for three
things that make you cold rain snow and
wind in the time it takes this dog to
collapse names for famous English people
B McKellen Rowan Atkinson Stephen Fry
and a brand sorry I'm not being there
you know actually I think in the time it
takes his dog to escape name for cartoon
characters
okay Bugs Bunny Bart Simpson Homer
Simpson and tickle a in the time it
takes this dog to steal a sausage name
five things beginning with P well
potatoes pants Paris paparazzi and
[Laughter]
love this dog when that as I said in the
time it takes this dog to break the
spaghetti twice name three current world
leaders trum yeah Oh
for example oh I'm sorry I I struggle to
get those names well I told you we were
competitive okay that's all right you
are forgiven